[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi avec un focus sur la
formation aux langues étrangères
sans oublier à notre rubrique consacrée
aux entreprises qui recrutent tout de
suite le sommaire l'hôtellerie est un
secteur d'activité où la maîtrise d'une
ou plusieurs langues est indispensable
illustration novotel saint quentin en
yvelines qui accueille tout au long de
la nuit une clientèle internationale
améliorer son niveau de l'an quand on
est chef d'entreprise c'est ce que
propose globe- langue soloceans basé à
guyancourt
claudine pierre directrice
administrative du sert elle sera
également en plateau pour nous présenter
ce centre d'études et de ressources en
langues de l'ue vs qu enfin si vous êtes
en recherche d'emploi ne manquez pas
notre rendez vous consacré aux
entreprises qui recrutent formateur en
langue ou encore vendeur à domicile
indépendant
prenez de quoi noter sia les métiers et
les secteurs d'activité qui font appel
aux compétences linguistiques sont de
plus en plus nombreux un avantage
notamment lorsque l'on travaille dans le
secteur de l'hôtellerie reportage
justement au novotel de saint quentin en
yvelines
[Musique]
nous sommes à magny-les-hameaux c'est
ici que sont implantés le golf national
mais aussi l'hôtel novotel saint quentin
en yvelines un établissement quatre
étoiles qui emploie une cinquantaine de
personnes en un mélange de clients un
tout un mélange de clients du lundi au
jeudi on a des clientèles corpo du
clientèle affaires presque 100 % à faire
à partir du vendredi samedi dimanche cd
clientèle loisirs golfique
on a beaucoup de clients étrangers
surtout des anglais écossais finlandais
en maintenant un brassard et d'arcueil
convoi d autres nationalités des
clientèles aussi qui vient de des arabes
unis
ici donc il ya plusieurs plusieurs
métiers puisque yahia l'accueil il ya la
restauration tous ces métiers là est ce
que les personnes qui travaillent dans
ces secteurs là est-ce qu'il faut qu'ils
sachent parler plusieurs langues
oui l'anglais est indispensable pour
pouvoir communiquer avec les to les
nationale est ailleurs car josé bonjour
vous êtes assistant chef de réception
ici dans cet hôtel alors cru nous
expliquer en quoi consiste votre métier
le poste d'assistant me permet en fait d
aider la réception lors des dédicaces
des check-in vu que concernant tel assez
grande et 131 chambres
on a des journées où on a vraiment
beaucoup d'eau causée par et d'arrivée
en même temps alors que nous explique un
petit peu votre votre parcours scolaire
j'ai fait mes études ici en france
c'était une licence en hôtellerie et
tourisme à l'international et c'est
vraiment une rivalité ation de ce que
j'avais fait avant
dans mon pays il est originaire
originaire des îles à vous parler
combien de langues
je parle trop un total donc ça sert à
les français l'espagnol l'anglais
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans ce métier
c'est justement peu pouvoir comme ça
parlait plusieurs langues
ça c'est une des choses qui est le plus
intéressant de travailler dans un hôtel
c'est qu'on peut échanger avec des
différents clients du monde entier dans
six mois le site accueillera la plus
prestigieuse compétition de golf au
monde
la ryder cup un événement où les langues
étrangères auront évidemment toute leur
importance
alors vous l'avez vu un bien sûr dans ce
sujet maîtriser une ou plusieurs langues
est important sur le marché du travail
des organismes de formation proposent
d'ailleurs des programmes pour les
salariés et les chefs d'entreprise on
prend tout de suite la direction de
guyancourt située à guyancourt globe
langue solution est un organisme de
formation linguistique
il propose des formations en langues
européennes
l'anglais ou bien l'allemand ou encore
des formations en langues rares comme le
chinois est destiné essentiellement aux
entreprises
laurent hénart bonjour un bonjour vous
êtes le gérant de globe langue solution
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler
des différentes formations que vous
proposez ici on cherche réellement à
accompagner donc des apprenants pour
qu'ils soient de plus en plus
performants dans leur travail et donc on
propose différentes solutions à ce titre
là que ce soit du présentiel donc du
face à face soit dans nos locaux soit
une entreprise également des solutions
de visio des solutions par téléphone on
accompagne également sur de la
traduction sont des préparations aux
entretiens de recrutement nous sommes en
général sur des programmes entre 40 et
60 heures qui se déroule sur l'année 1
sur des rythmes qui sont hebdomadaires
et sont à peu près des modules 1h30 à 2h
à chacune des séances
votre société existe depuis 1994 est ce
que depuis cette date à vous avez vu
justement une
demande de plus en plus forte justement
pour wii comme on sait les uns et les
autres on est ouvert à la mondialisation
donc aujourd'hui on peut pas faire
autrement que de s'intéresser et de
communiquer avec avec des langues
étrangères
une fois le plus on développe aussi de
la formation interculturelle parce qu'on
considère que parler une langue
étrangère c'est bien mais comprendre
aussi l'interlocuteur auquel on va
s'adresser
quelle est sa culture quel est son
habitude ses coutumes et tout ça
[Musique]
vous êtes ici ce que cette chef
d'entreprise et vous voyagez beaucoup
notamment à travers la france et vous
êtes souvent ici sur paris voilà si vous
avez connu globe langue solution alors
justement qu'est-ce qui vous plaît dans
cette formation c'est une formation de
60 heures c'est bien c'est ça voilà ce
qui me plaît énormément c'est encore une
fois c'est cette flexibilité
c'est cette écoute des formateurs déjà à
la base y'a vraiment eu une analyse mme
lemay besoins et bien évidemment on a
cette facilité pour parler anglais pour
se débrouiller au quotidien néanmoins
quand on commence à rentrer dans les
sujets un petit peu complexe et qu'il
faut négocier
c'est bien d'être accompagné par des
experts à la fois en amont et en aval
par le biais de débriefing là vous avez
un programme de 2 60 heures vous en
mettra combien là j'arrive à 40 heures à
peu près d'accord
est-ce que vous avez déjà atteindre
votre objectif non je suis
perfectionniste donc on n'atteint jamais
jamais mais disons qu'on ressent quand
même plus de sérénité
[Musique]
aujourd'hui globe langue solutions
compte une centaine de clients répartis
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines et m'a rejoint sur ce plateau
claudine pierre bonsoir invention vous
êtes la directrice administrative du crl
alors le crl c'est le centre d'étude et
de ressources en langue à lui vs qu il
existe trois sites dont 8 août a fait il
existe un site à guyancourt bien entendu
qui est le plus gros seirel je dirais de
l'ue vs q mais il existe également un
site insérées là versailles à l'ufr des
sciences est inséré lamente sur le site
de l'iut
alors est ce que l on nous parle un
petit peu du fonctionnement du crl il y
a plusieurs formules
ah oui plusieurs formules effectivement
donc nous sommes nous proposons bien sûr
des formations en langues
que ce soit en présentiel pour au cours
d'ateliers d'expression orale
individuels ou collectifs ou bien aussi
à distance parce que maintenant de plus
en plus les apprenants sont a envie de
travailler de chez eux et de ne pas
forcément se déplacer mais nous avons
toujours aussi le laboratoire de langues
ou vous pouvez venir travailler
avec l'accompagnement de la responsable
pédagogique qui va vous guider tout au
long de votre parcours
alors qu'ils peuvent venir au crl des
étudiants enfin tout le monde mesure des
étudiants des scolaires mais aussi les
particuliers et nous en avons quelques
ans ainsi que des des personnes des
salariés qui souhaitent utiliser leur
cpf par exemple pour se perfectionner en
anglais et se préparer au taux unique et
le test of english internationals
communication' qui est notamment de
souvent demandée est très souvent
demandé maintenant pour accéder à
certains postes
ça vous donne un score qui vous
déterminez votre niveau d'anglais
donc le crl prépare à ce test est fait
également passer le test puisque nous
sommes centre de test à gré pour le
tohic alors vous parlez d'anglais l'on
peut être formé imagina à d'autres
langues sur nous proposons plusieurs
langues à guyancourt par exemple en ce
moment nous avons des ateliers
d'espagnol d'anglais bien sûr d'italiens
d'allemand nous faisons aussi beaucoup
de français langue étrangère
et cette année nous proposons également
du russe en atelier d'expression orale
laisser langues se retrouve bien
évidemment aussi soit dans notre labo
soit dans nos formations à distance
alors qu'est-ce qui est le plus demandé
comme formule c'est très variable selon
les individus il ya des individus qui
préfèrent uniquement le présentiel et
être accompagnés tout au long donc ils
feront essentiellement des ateliers
d'expression orale et travailleront sur
site dans notre labo d'autres qui font
juste des ateliers et travailleront sur
la plateforme à distance toutes les
solutions sont existe en fait selon les
personnalités
et les impératifs de chacun alors
question pratique comment ça se passe
donc alors vous avez un site internet
évidemment oui ouf plusieurs
informations il ya j'imagine un rendez
vous donc à prendre avec le sert elle
idéalement on peut venir nous sommes
ouverts tous les jours de la semaine il
suffit de venir où on prendre un rendez
vous c'est encore mieux parce que vous
trouverez des personnes disponibles pour
vous conseiller
avoir un entretien avec vous déterminez
vos besoins et en fonction de ça vous
proposer un parcours pédagogique
donc voila nous proposons des formations
qui sont éligibles au cpf nerfs question
c'est est-ce que vous avez vu ça à la
demande de plus en plus forte ces
dernières années on voyait dans l'est
dans les reportages on parle beaucoup il
demande de mondialisation il ya de plus
en plus de personnes justement ces
dernières années qui sont venus aux
céréales pour se perfectionner oui alors
on a de plus en plus de demandes
notamment parce que les entreprises ou
même les écoles pour recruter requiert
d'avoir un ce corps tonique de
785 ce qui est un niveau b2 si on veut
parler en jargon c'est à dire un niveau
presque bilingue
enfin intermédiaire en tout cas en
anglais et ça devient de plus en plus
important maintenant pour les personnes
de pouvoir justifier d'un niveau en
anglais sur leur cv pour trouver un
travail
merci et claudine pierre d'avoir accepté
notre invitation retrouve évidemment
toutes ces informations sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran
alors à présent si vous êtes à la
recherche d'un emploi et bien un conseil
prenez de quoi noter voici plusieurs
offres d'emploi proposées par deux
entreprises de notre territoire
bonjour loin la fin je suis gérant de
blob langue solution qui est un
organisme de formation linguistique basé
sur guyancourt aujourd'hui nous sommes
en plein développement est en pleine
croissance et donc à la recherche
permanente de formateurs qui sont
certifiés formation formateur ce soit
delta que ce soit au sol et puis
également nous sommes à la recherche
d'un gestionnaire ou du gestionnaire de
formation pour notre activité
si jamais vous avez se profiler vous
êtes intéressé par ce type de poste
n'hésitez pas donc à nous envoyer votre
candidature sur notre site internet ou à
nous contacter bonjour donc tu
m'appelles pascal rault je suis la
directrice des agences d'île de france
ouest chez vorwerk thermomix depuis
quatre ans une société en pleine
évolution et aujourd'hui donc nous avons
la vocation de recruter 80 personnes sur
le secteur du 78 ascione et de cuisine
vous avez envie d'en faire votre
activité soit à temps choisi en tant que
vaidéhi donc vendeur à domicile
indépendant soit de développer cette
activité en activité principale et
devenir vrp ou alors de d'évoluer aussi
ou de venir directement comme
responsable de secteur ou là vous avez
plus une vocation de manager et
d'animation d'équipé ou alors postulez
aussi pour un poste de responsable
directeur d'agencé pour les futures
agences qui seront à créer sur toute la
france pour tout renseignement vous
pouvez donc contacté l'agent ce d'île de
france ouest / agence pointé m
point ile de france ouest @ vorwerk
point fr voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi 10 avril pour un nouveau mode
d'emploi à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]